you watching fireworks if you're
enjoying it then hug a chemist yes what
you're seeing is the display of colors
brought to you by an entire portfolio of
elements from the periodic table that
are burning it's like that aluminum
barium calcium chlorine copper nitrogen
oxygen sodium
elements plucked from the periodic table
and burned and when they burn they
radiate in a characteristic
configuration of colors we call this in
astrophysics they're Spectrum each
element has a unique pattern of
wavelengths of light that it sends out
when it's burned and a clever designer
of fireworks will get certain
combinations of these elements and they
will form the color palette of the
particular shot of fireworks you're
looking at